I would have much preferred to have come
to the dinner tonight from a slightly
closer residence but it does strike me
that in the last few days at least
FoxNews seems to think that's where I
live in the White House
because they spend a disproportionate
amount of their time talking about
impeaching me so look if they want to
make a trade I'd be more than willing no
we're just pointing out potential crimes
and corruption that you have had and we
believe in equal justice under the law
and what you did was inexplicable
Hillary that was her over the weekend
once again talked attacking Fox News and
obviously us because we dare to tell the
truth about the scandal surrounding her
we want equal justice under the law we
can tell you more what we're Speaker of
the House Newt Newt Gingrich all right
the very thing they have been accusing
president Trump on his campaign oh no
evidence after a year we now know
they're guilty of we now know that
Clinton's campaign the DNC and now we
learned over the weekend Barack Obama
about ten million dollars over ten
million dollars of money spent to a law
firm they all it used the same law firm
to funnel money to this Christopher
Steele that gets phony information from
Russia this the salacious dossier using
Russian sources to influence Americans
in the last election when is Muller
going to investigate that because we
know the money exchange stands we know
it was propaganda and misinformation
well I look I think this is the real
test of Mullah right early on I said I
thought he had a record for being
honorable I frankly would drew that
after looking at who he was hiring how
he was operating what he was doing it's
gonna be fascinating this is I'm my
tomorrow's big productions I've been
telling people when you surround
yourself with only Obama Clinton donors
no Trump donors and you look at the
metaphor thing and it's so far removed
from his original mission which was to
look at Trump Russia collusion I have
been telling people he wants to use
Manta Ford squeeze him in the hopes he
wants to take down Trump tell me I'm
crazy
sure no I don't I don't disagree with
you my point is now we have a chance
from a little to prove he really is
nonpartisan he really is about believe
it and it's easy first he got first he
goes I didn't say I believed it either I
said there he has a chance to prove it
yes sir he goes after he goes after Tony
Podesta then he goes after Tony's
brother
John then he goes down the list of the
Clinton people I mean if he's prepared
to be genuinely open and to really go
after the Clinton case and here's what I
found as I've said Malthus during the
commercial break the most sobering thing
about this entire unbelievable scandal
is if she had won none of this would be
coming out let me think about it they
would have covered it up they would have
continued to to corrupt the FBI that had
continued to corrupt the Justice
Department we would have learned nothing
about how horrible this is and they
would have continued I think to sellout
America's interest it is an astonishing
gap and people who wonder about whether
or not it was important that President
Trump won you think about the difference
between the what we're learning now and
what would have been covered up by
Hillary Clinton bribery extortion money
laundering racketeering and Muller and
Eric Holder and the FBI informant with
evidence in 2009 they didn't stop the
uranium one deal and they knew Putin was
at the bottom of it let me ask you this
talk about the fairness of a grand jury
process you can indict a ham sandwich
this is in an area where Hillary Clinton
DC a good friend of mine pointed out ken
starr couldn't get an indictment against
the Clintons or a conviction there ever
and yet this is the area that is now
being used in this campaign it seems
like there's an injustice when it's so
overwhelmingly left-wing liberal
Democrat oh sure look this goes all the
way back to John Connally in 1979 being
indicted by a grand jury of up there was
a hundred percent Democrats and
eventually winning the jury trial but
it's very uphill and very difficult and
I think a good prosecutor remember that
all the grand jury is saying is that
there is a reasonable grounds to look at
this the test for an actual trial is the
opposite the tests that traffic laws
yeah guilty beyond a reasonable doubt
huge stuff so I don't I don't think you
sort of manically respond just to that
but the point I was trying to make a
minute ago I want to come back to
because this is a direct challenge to
our molar if he is sincerely interested
in justice he has to go after the
hundred and forty five million in Canada
he has to go after Bill Clinton's him a
half million dollars he's got to go
after all the different permutations
that we've now learned about including
the stuff that when he was FBI director
was covered up now I'm with you in that
I have a hunch he'll fail this test but
I think it's a fascinating moment in
American history particularly when you
had Tony Podesta resign because he now
knows he's so guilty he doesn't want to
take his entire firm down with him and
you forgot Trump I have another
challenge look at the the funding of
Clinton and now Obama and the DNC for
phony Russian propaganda that was
repeated by everybody to influence an
American election we know they did that
that's a fact at this point right it
turns out the Trump's the definition of
fake news I'm not sure he said in
Russian well you know an absolute proof
there was fake news cheerfully carried
up by several the networks the New York
Times and it was false in fact I'll be
fascinated to see if I'm again the major
elite news media goes back and looks at
how much they were duped
Hillary DNC Obama bought and paid for
Russian propaganda to influence an
election we can follow the money mr.
speaker you've been great well thank you
what glass part I see something good
coming go ahead no I'm just going to say
could you imagine the New York Times or
The Washington Post reporting here are
the ways we were duped would that be
like a Pulitzer Prize winning moment
yeah but hell will freeze over and we
were right and they were wrong and
they'll never admit it good to see you
sir thank you
up neck